thirty years ago one of these guys might
have gone out taking his own life and
committed suicide today they go out and
shoot some place up this is a
quintessential American issue his fear
what drives in the jewelry of gun sales
does it promote gun sales of course it
does his mom calls me around buy
something the morning and she says had
been an accident and immediately I go
you just have kids are just done the gun
has become a symbol of far more than
just the gun as an issue in and of
itself President Obama is trying to make
terrorism into guns and it's not guns
folks it is not guns well the election
of President Trump was really bad for
the cause of stopping gun violence in
this country power money money in power
in a world where you don't think I
matter and you don't give a damn about
me man having a gun all of a sudden that
makes me somebody
[Music]
you